water while you wait
this is what going on holiday through
the euro tunnel looks like today
a two-hour wait for some of these people
and their pets
and only one answer when we asked why
david cameron david
brexit and why'd you say that i don't
know it's just messed everything up this
has happened because of brexit hasn't it
basically we're very anti-brexit
it used to be fast to france and on to
the continent but now traffic moves at a
snail's pace
this is what the aaa is describing as a
hot spot of holiday hell and this is why
we've just walked from the entrance of
the euro tunnel and this is the back of
the queue and it's taken us half an hour
to do that walk and during that time the
traffic has barely moved
ultimately brexit was inevitably going
to mean longer queues at both dover for
the ferries and foxton fort euro tunnel
beforehand you could just wave your
passport at the border official all he
or she could do if they wanted to check
it was just have a look and make sure
that you were the person on the photo
now they have to stamp your passport
we asked those with foreign number
plates whether it's any different coming
into the uk from the continent
on the other side it's usually pretty
pretty quick smooth
very smooth
i think it's a problem getting out
eurotunnel says it's brought in more
staff and is working at full capacity
we've put on additional trains by
comparison to the middle of the week in
watermore the winter so that we're at
peak service right the way through this
weekend
with additional support to get people
through the terminal
by this afternoon the wait times seem to
be around two hours
but for some people joining the queue
that's perhaps a little too long sadia
chowdhury sky news in foxton in kent